okay so you guys have been screaming at
me to continue the dark knights of steel
and i was gonna wait until the uh until
the sixth issue comes out because i
believe that wraps up the first story
arc but uh i kind of figured what in the
hay right might as well just kind of
keep on and then we'll just cover the
sixth issue when it comes out so this is
the fourth issue and this is basically
the origin of what i call the
unstoppable batman right i think it's
just it's a cool name right like i think
it's just uh calling him the unstoppable
batman is just kind of a cool idea until
we actually get a definitive name for
him whatever version of batman dc
chooses to call him but again in the
last video that we did which covered the
first three issues we had basically come
to this revelation that bruce wayne as
he exists in this alternate reality
instead of being the son of thomas and
martha wayne was actually the son of
jorel and martha wayne that there was
kind of an affair there and so at the
end of that we kind of had this
revelation from alfred where he
basically told bruce i'm going to tell
you everything right now again if you
guys want to make sure you check the
description you'll find a link to the
playlist for this series and uh and
that'll get you all caught up it'll just
be the last video in this video but
nonetheless right it'll get you caught
up on everything that's going on and so
what alfred says here is that he was
there when jorell and lara or lara if
you want to call her that crash landed
on earth while the townspeople weren't
exactly sure what to make of this at the
end of the day the elves just kind of
kept to themselves just sort of lived
out there in the world they didn't
really bother anybody and just sort of
did their thing so ultimately nobody was
too concerned about them but all this
changed when there was just an
earthquake that had taken place now
initially jorel wakes up out of fear you
know kind of having this this kind of
throwback to the events of krypton when
it was exploding and that's when larry's
like no no no we're not on krypton
anymore everything's cool except for the
earthquake we're having right that is a
problem and so because of the fact that
remember they are kryptonians existing
on a planet with a yellow sun their
powers manifest exactly the way that you
would expect them to right super
strength super speed x-ray vision heat
vision all that kind of stuff the
traditional powers of superman that
basically manifests in the form of uh of
his parents and so when they take off
what they realize is that there is a uh
there's a mountain out here called mount
kristoff basically an active volcano
that is about to erupt and that it'll
happen within two days and that
everything they've built would basically
be destroyed but the response is we can
build again but when the question is
asked of you know by lara like what of
the kingdom out there that's when they
say okay like if we reveal ourselves we
may have to leave for another home the
people here might not accept us but at
the end of the day the possibility of
being able to stay here and save lives
outweighs the guilt that they would
experience by never warning anybody and
letting the town's people die and so
because of their their advanced
understanding of technology and so on
and so forth they were able to basically
start drafting plans right as it stated
they demonstrate how the wayne's army
could work to stave off disaster if they
started that day the plans included
where to build trenches to divert the
lava how to sow mass for the hot ash and
the smoke trajectories of potential
molten rock falls all that kind of stuff
like literally a full-scale plan on how
to overcome this now remember in this
alternate reality thomas and martha
wayne rule this entire kingdom right
they're the king and queen of this part
of the world and so because of this it's
not very easy for jordael to just show
up on their doorstep and meet with them
instead what he ends up doing is
basically passing the plans on to the
advisors to thomas and martha wayne this
advisor basically being lex luthor and
that what happens here is that because
lex luthor is a prideful man and is
arrogant has his own beliefs he
ultimately burns the plans of jorel and
lara and never tells the waynes what's
going on and so ultimately what ends up
happening is that as time progresses no
progress is being made on these plans
and the volcanic eruption gets closer
and closer you end up having jorel who
literally busts into the kingdom right
like just storms into the castle of
thomas and of thomas and martha wayne
and it's like and literally asks luther
like like what are you doing like why
have you not evacuated yet and when
thomas is like what's this guy talking
about that's when it dawns on jorel that
luther had never told thomas and martha
wayne about what was happening here that
the mountain was about to erupt the
reason why lex luthor hadn't done this
is he said i read the ancient records
right the mountain has always been angry
and has never threatened us i also
consulted the stars now at this point in
in humanity or at least in this
alternate reality humans are pretty
primitive right kind of dumb right you
know reading the stars and consulting
ancient scrolls right in the face of
jorel and lara they're like you're an
idiot right like i mean we come from a
ridiculously advanced civilization we
know this mountain is about to erupt
right like we know this is about to
happen you have to do something right
you're reading burning balls of gas for
their insight that's what you're doing
you're asking stars on what you should
do they're burning balls of gas
millions of light years away and you're
trying to figure out what you should do
but the problem is it's ultimately too
late the mountain ends up erupting and
when that happens there is an attempt
that's made by lex luthor to seize uh
jorel and lara which of course leads to
everybody realizing they're effectively
unstoppable right like they literally
try to stab him with spears and like
nothing happens right the spirits just
bounce right off of him but in the end
because of the fact that they display
just these almost magical powers in
nature right i mean as far as these
humans are concerned thomas and martha
and everybody else here they're they're
almost godly in terms of power the
response of lara is like we're here as
friends and so it's like you guys stay
here we'll basically take care of it and
so jorel and lara end up going through
and essentially quelling any issues with
the mountain right blocking the lava
flows and all that kind of stuff
essentially everything that they had
planned now what also happens is that
because lex luthor was basically an
idiot decided to consult the stars for
what he should do in the midst of a
volcanic eruption he's ultimately exiled
right he's expelled from the kingdom
kicked out right just banned entirely
like there's no way for him to come back
his name is is stricken from the record
books as far as anybody's concerned if
he ever shows up here again they'll
probably end up destroying him the
caveat to this is that in mount kristoff
was an artifact a glowing green artifact
that had basically emerged lex luthor
not knowing what it was approached it
and all we're really told here by uh
alfred is that luther was not seen again
until the day with uh with with thomas
and martha wayne right until the day of
wayne's parents and that what had
happened is that over the time that had
taken place after saving the town's
people that while lara and jorel weren't
really like you know they didn't really
replace thomas and martha wayne as king
and queen because the citizens really
paid homage to the idea of like the
monarchy and the royal bloodline and all
that kind of stuff they were just
championed as heroes right their word
was their bond everybody loved them
right everybody absolutely adored them
they shared technology with everyone not
so much that it just sent them into a
highly advanced state but enough to just
kind of be like here's some cool stuff
that you could probably consider doing
but the other part of this is that
because thomas wayne spent so much time
focusing on his kingdom he was
neglectful of martha and that in what
alfred describes as a moment of weakness
the two of them slept together right the
two of them were in bed together and
this is something that jorel had
confessed to lara and is something that
uh that martha had confessed to thomas
wayne and so of course they weren't
necessarily dishonest in so far as like
hiding it but they basically confessed
and ultimately cheated on their own
individual partners and so because of
this uh the the other thing to contend
with is that thomas wayne basically
couldn't bear children right like he
couldn't have children with his wife and
so the result of this is that when she
gave birth to bruce all this anger and
all this this feeling of betrayal right
this resentment that came with knowing
that his wife had cheated on him and
that she had become pregnant by another
man which is something that thomas wayne
wasn't able to achieve that this
basically led to him really beginning to
understand and to actually start loving
his son once he started focusing on that
instead right resentment began to give
way and instead all that kind of fell to
the wayside raising bruce alongside uh
kal-el giving them the best possible
future they could have that was the
important thing and so what this does is
it leads to the point where you have
thomas and martha wayne basically
setting out for amazonia right and it's
really kind of a all the families that
are setting out for amazonia but once
they set out there right for the realm
of amazon essentially the realm of
wonder woman right that territory to
kind of meet with them and most likely
for you know one part vacation one part
political events right you know just
kind of a meeting of the kingdoms to
make sure that hey you know we just want
to make sure you don't want to wage war
against us you know like that kind of a
thing that when this happens the
carriage or really both carriages are
essentially attacked by what's referred
to as the green man and that's what
alfred says right alfred says i didn't
know he was still out there i didn't
know what the ring was that burst from
mount kristoff and what it had been
whispering in his mind and he refers to
him as the green man the cruel joker the
man once known as lex luthor what it
looks like here is that lex luthor has
become both the joker and a green
lantern at the same time which is crazy
imagine that like one i don't even know
how the ring works in this universe if
if joker can become the green lantern
but i guess it kind of makes sense right
like green lantern rings aren't
necessarily passed down on goodness
right it's just like you know such and
such you have the ability to overcome
great fear welcome to the green lantern
court it doesn't necessarily say like
such and such you have the ability to
overcome great fear and you've always
been a good guy welcome to the green
lantern court we kind of assume they're
synonymous but i don't know if there's
anything that really says that they are
right but obviously the green artifact
that shot out of mount uh mount kristoff
that was the green lantern ring and so
what you end up having is this fight
that breaks out between uh between the
joker and between jorel now of course
this is also you know as a result of
thomas wayne being completely
incinerated martha herself actually ends
up succumbing to her to her injuries but
before that happens she tells lara she
says look like bruce wayne he'll be
considered a bastard by the people who
are in this land they will never see him
as a rightful heir because he is not the
biological son of myself and thomas he's
the biological son of myself and jorel
however he is at least half royal blood
and so where where she says like the
people will initially reject them the
people believe in you and so you will
have to convince the people you will
have to get them to believe that he is
the best person to be ruler once we have
passed on and she says but until that
time where he's able to step in and
become ruler i want you and jorel to
rule our kingdom in our place we will
not be there to to bear witness to
everything we will not be there to rule
the kingdom so you have to look after
bruce look after him for us take care of
him treat him as one of your own and
rule the kingdom in our stead we know
that you will do what's right and then
of course she ultimately ends up passing
on she ultimately ends up dying and so
again at that point things switch back
over to alfred basically addressing
bruce and that's when bruce fully comes
to terms with what happens right that
alfred says i know the doubt in your
mind bruce but you are the son of thomas
and martha wayne it's just you're also
something more stop thinking you're not
worthy of them they were hardly perfect
people none of us are with jor-el's
murder we are on the cusp of war as the
only survivor of a war i will do
anything to avoid that and so bruce asks
like do you have a plan and the response
of alfred is no but i have a king
basically illustrating he trusts in
bruce wayne to make the right decision
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end uh hopefully
this satisfies
[Laughter]
your all's need to see more of the the
dark knights of steel don't worry we
will cover issue number five next week
and then hopefully by then issue number
six will come out if not we'll just have
to wait for it to come out before we can
cover it so i know you guys are
oftentimes like rob you gotta do the
next issue i can't do it until it comes
out because it's not out so like we'll
just have to wait with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace